Early stage investors want to invest
in people around them because
they want to help.
They want to be there
on a regular basis and
go through this super difficult
thing of building a startup.
So, usually,
your early investors are going to come
from the immediate vicinity around you.
If there are no such investors around
you that are aligned with your business
or you feel you can reach out to,
I think putting yourself in
a position where you can find ways.
So for example if you are not
in a big metropolitan,
perhaps going to accelerator program for
a few months.
Perhaps thinking about where the best
place to set up your business maybe
closer to your customers that
might be in a large metropolitan.
I think those are some of the things you
should be thinking about in order to get
close to the investors.
Because investors, it's not about giving
you a check and wishing you good luck.
They want to be there for you.
They want to help you and for
that they feel they need to be
geographically located next to you.